hello and welcome to this video i'm
playing
3dp 3t with black
okay so
e6 and we have a nimzo
no i can i can play d5 or c5 here i just
i have um okay
i have written a book on c5 and a
chester will cause
with d5 so
clearly
both moves
i can play this is interesting f4
it's a bit of an odd move order usually
you start with
e4 isn't d5
interesting here
yeah but that must be a good pawn
structure
for black
just that that looks pretty ugly
honestly
take here just to
take with the queen
and then we get to an iqp here
yeah that is good for good for black for
sure
the question is only
how much of an advantage it is
okay maybe
start with the rook move
he goes to b2
i can definitely play 95 i'm just
wondering what the right
move order is you can also think about
knight to e4
you know it's a tough one probably it's
it's the best decision to simply make
reasonably quick moves and
then see what happens
it's increment though i don't have to
worry
about
time scrambles all that much 95 is a
tempo
on the pawn he puts another pawn
on a dark square
so i think i'll trade one
and now get the king to d6
or d7 for that matter um
i wonder if what about um
i don't know i wonder if a5 is an idea
for white
that that is worth stopping i think i
think i'll stop it
i think it's good king d7
okay the king is covering
all the entry squares on the c file and
now i'm threatening rook e3 check
with invasion
don't don't see how he's stopping that
honestly
king f3 i don't know that was such a
well-timed decision
knight e3 doesn't do much but i can
enter like that
and now he has to be cautious here with
with the
rook c2
i i was winning already with knight
before
here i'm winning with knight c3 though i
believe
sorry with rook c3 is there anything
better maybe
[Music]
no it's a completely clean window he has
to trade
and i just win the a4 pawn it was one of
the ideas of a5 fixing it on a light
square actually
so that it can never be defended by the
bishop
so i want to cover d5
so
he's not ever not even getting in pawn
to d5
no yeah this is fine
and now the two pawns do the job
um aa3 or
you know i mean it's clear that
oh that many moves win but
okay so let's have a look i i honestly
think that
we have to look for
improvements pretty early on because the
position
was really not good for white at all
even though you don't have to lose it in
the way that it happened
so here the absolutely normal move is e4
after which black goes knight to e8
preventing the bishop g5 pin and then we
continue from there
usually with f4 bishop e3 is also a move
f4 f5 is what is normally played here
okay so he went f4 and
i don't know d5 now looks pretty good
because
i'm fighting for those light squares and
if
i mean what what exactly is he doing now
um
besides what he did in the game i mean
that just
kills his bishop here putting this on f4
i took on d5 i took queen shakes
c4 wow
that is an interesting move
i mean i i know why the engine suggests
it actually
i mean this is clearly a very nice
position
we have fantastic compensation here with
all the
great light squares and this is more
than enough for a pawn
and the the drawback what i did in the
game is the capture here d
takes that is what you should have done
because this
might still be it's also bad actually
but it's it probably um
still offers more resistance than the
game
this looks good though yeah okay in the
game c4 was played and now
i went for this simplification
and for this pretty one-sided ending
no this is
definitely a lot better for black but it
starts to be
probably over
only a couple of moves later king f2
king d7 king f3 and now it's over here
and it's just such an awful position now
the engine wants to play rook c4
rookie 8 bishop c1 and then f5
you know i can centralize this even
though it's not
totally obvious how to how to win
from there i always have this idea
to simply trade rooks that would i think
in most cases
already win like here if i play
hmm is it better
to do something on the kings side first
or
i i'm wondering if this wins right the
computer says
it does not win okay and i understand
why because
the computer shows that white is
just in time to stop b5
if i would be able to play b5 get an
outside past
a pawn i would win easily but he is in
time to
go there okay that means i have to still
fight for i can play rook
e6 actually and then rook c6
how is that not winning
let's say king f3 rook c6
and that wins okay so that is a
straightforward plan
actually rook e66 looks very strong okay
so
white is already in in big trouble and
here
he is lost i think rook b3
and then rook c3 then
and i just win the the pawn and have to
connect the pesos
okay that was a i think pretty
instructive win out of the nimzo indian
zamish thanks for watching